we still use many of the laws that were
passed during Grant's presidency to
prosecute insurrectionists so the 900 or
so people who have been prosecuted for
breaking into the capital and attacking
police on January 6. those
insurrectionists they've been prosecuted
under the 1871 anti-clu Klux Klan law so
that's a big accomplishment by Grant and
we still benefit from it the problem is
Grant was not a great politician unlike
Lincoln
he didn't give good speeches he wasn't a
persuasive figure in a political space
and so he had trouble building support
for what he was doing even though he was
trying to do what in the end I think
were the right things what was the role
of the KKK at that time so the Ku Klux
Klan is formed at the end of the Civil
War by Confederate Veterans first in
Tennessee in Pulaski Tennessee and then
it spreads elsewhere and there are other
groups that are similar the red shirts
and various others these are veterans of
the Confederate Army who come home
and are committed to continuing the war
they are going to use their power at
home and their weapons to intimidate and
if necessary kill people who challenge
their Authority not just African
Americans Jews Catholics various others
they are going to basically protect the
continued rule of the same families who
own the slaves before in post-slavery
Tennessee and post-slavery South
Carolina and when we get to voting
they're often the groups that are
preventing people from voting the white
sheets and the ritual around that was
all an effort to provide a certain
ritualistic legitimacy and hide identity
though everyone knew who they were oh so
that that whole brand that whole
practice was there from from have you
studied the KKK it's history a little
bit I have and there are a number of
other historians who have too so I've
used their research as well I'm kind of
curious I have to admit that my
knowledge of it is very kind of
caricature knowledge I'm sure there's
interesting stories and threads because
I think there's there different
competing organizations or something
like that of course within the United
States and I feel like they through that
lens you can tell a story of the United
States also of these different they're
often business associations I mean
there's a lot of work showing that
they're actually people join the KKK for
the reasons I just laid out but also
because it was networking for your
business you gained legitimacy in the
area that you that you were in so this
these were
Community groups that were formed to
help white business people they helped
white sheriffs get elected what we have
to understand today is when we're
debating policing this history matters
enormously right I I have nothing
against police my cousin one of my
closest relatives just retired from 25
years in the New York Police Department
thank God he survived I have deep
respect he's one of the best public
servants I know but what we also have to
recognize as we respect police officers
is that for many communities
in our country they know this history
and the KKK in the 1870s and in the
1930s you look at any KKK organization
as I have in my research and you find
the police Chiefs or the KKK members the
local police officers local judges
because it was how you became police
chief so the these groups infiltrated
some of the main institutions in our in
our nation I don't even think they
infiltrated I think they were part of
those institutions the deeper question
today in the 21st century is uh one how
much of that is still there and how much
of the history of that reverberates to
the institutions and I'm making the
latter point that it's not there that
much now but people remember it well and
some people would even say it's not
there at all that there is not
institutional racism or policing
uh but if if that's the case then you
can also say that if there is not direct
institutional racism there what is it
the Echoes of History still have effects
of course and that and that's and that's
really important that we have to take
that seriously that's not an excuse for
people then saying nasty things about
the police but it is what we have to
recognize look I'm Jewish and there are
certain
um elements of Russian Behavior today I
see in Ukraine that reverberate with the
history of how my grandparents dealt
with pogroms in Russia right even though
what Putin is doing in Ukraine might not
technically be a pogrom that history
matters and how I view these issues and
and that's a reality yeah I had I went
to 7-Eleven recently
and uh uh what did I eat ate one of
their salads
I'm sorry I love 7-Eleven I'm sorry it's
one of the cells and got like terrible
food poisoning oh I was suffering for
like four days and now I can't I love
seven I love going to 7-Eleven late at
night in sweatpants and just I escaped
the world I'm listening to an audiobook
and now every time I pass that salad for
the rest of my life I would have hate
for that salad so history matters even
if the salad is no longer have any bad
stuff in it it's probably the lettuce or
something whatever
um mostly for humor's sake but I'm also
giving a a kind of metaphor that
um history can have an individual and a
large-scale society effect on on human
interactions both the good and the bad
if you actually recommend to me offline
books on the KKK they'll be really happy
to there were a few mentioned in in the
in the footnotes in my book here and
also in part because I also want to
understand the white nationalism and
white supremacists uh Christian
supremacists of Christian nationalism
all those different subgroups in the
United States and also around the world
I'm a bit
my mind has been focused on some of the
better aspects of human nature that it's
nice to also understand uh some of the
darker aspects
um let me ask you sort of a personal
question for me do you think it's
possible
do you think it's useful to do a podcast
conversation with somebody like David
Duke
or somebody
so somebody that everybody knows
so it's not like you're giving a
platform to to somebody that's a hidden
um
member of the KKK or like uh it's sort
of putting a a pretty face on some dark
ideas but everybody knows and so now
you're just exploring you're sitting
across the table maybe not in his case
um maybe somebody who's an active KKK
member sitting across from a person that
literally hates me
Flex I think that's fascinating too I do
too I I think uh so long as what you are
doing
is not boosting someone so taking an
obscure figure
and making that figure now famous yes uh
but if it's someone who's already
Infamous yeah and it helps us to
understand them and as so long as your
effort
is to ask them tough questions which you
do right you don't you don't give them
all the questions in advance you don't
have limitations on what you can ask so
long as it is a real interview not
pablum then I'm for it what I'm what I'm
against is a softball interview that
allows someone to sound reasonable when
they're not uh but the way I've seen you
do this when you've had figures like
that I won't name who have in mind but
when I've seen that is I I think that's
I think that's useful because honestly
uh the historian and me and the citizen
in me wants to understand
um my my Jewish grandfather always was
the the first to be against any effort
to suppress anti-semites because his
view was he wanted to know who they were
and he wanted to know what they thought
so he could be prepared
and I also see like perhaps as a
historian
you may be able to appreciate this kind
of thing that's probably how you see the
world but
there's several ways to see a human
being like Vladimir Putin is an example
one is a political figure that's
currently
doing actions on the world geopolitics
internally the politics of Russia but
there's also that human being in a
historical context
and collecting information about that
person in the historical context is also
very valuable so you could see
interviews with Hitler
in uh 39 40 41 as being very bad and
detrimental
to all that is good in the world but at
the same time it's important to
understand that human mind how it uh how
power affects that mind how power
corrupts it how they see the world
absolutely absolutely I would be all in
favor and maybe he will if Vladimir
Putin would sit down with you absolutely
I I don't think you're boosting someone
like that when you ask them tough
questions in fact I think that's what we
need to do those sorts of figures tend
to insulate themselves from tough
questions so just to restate I I am for
the Lex Friedman interview of uh those
sorts of figures I am not for the puff
piece on Fox and Friends uh where they
just come on and they're asked oh isn't
it tell us what you think of this tell
us what you think of that yeah so but
there's a balance there because
a lot of people that interview somebody
like Vladimir Putin all they do is
heart-handing questions they often
demonstrate a lack of knowledge of the
perspective of the Russian people and
the president there's not an empathy to
understand that this is a popularly
elected uh you can criticize that notion
but this is still the area that
represents the beliefs of a large number
of people and they have their own life
story they see the world they believe
they're doing good for the world and I
don't
um that idea
seems to not permeate the questions and
the thoughts that people say because
they're afraid of being attacked by the
people back home fellow journalists for
not being hard enough well maybe I think
that's probably true I think in my
experience with interviewers is that a
lot of them are really lazy you're not
which is why I like talking
can I just say okay this is not you
saying it can I just rant
if you're sitting across from Xi Jinping
from Vladimir Putin you you you should
be fired if you have not read like at
least several books on the guy the the
surprising lack of research that people
do leading up to it right so you need to
be a historian or a biographer you need
to be the kind of person that writes
biographies or histories before you sit
in front of the person not uh uh not a
low effort journalist and it's so
surprising to me that I think they're
probably really busy and it's probably
not part of the culture of the people
that do interviews to do deep deep like
investigative you need to be the kind of
person that lives that idea like see it
as a documentary that you work on for
three years kind of thing anyway that uh
of course some journalists do do that
and they do that masterfully and that's
the best of Journalism but I think a lot
of the times when the questions are as
you said uh out of touch with the
society that person that person is
leading it's because the interviewer
hasn't taken the time and I understand
uh you can't be an expert on every
subject but you can do what you do right
you read my book to prepare for this you
look things up you had a sense of the
person you're talking to and you put the
time in to do that this is what I always
tell my students right the secret to
success in anything is outworking other
people be more prepared right what you
show is like an iceberg it's the tip of
the iceberg right is what what people
see it's all the work that goes on below
the surface and if you work hard enough
which I aspire to do at the end of the
day just like an animal farm you'll be
like the horse boxer and slaughtered
unjustly by those that are much more
powerful than you because you'll be
happy when you're slaughtered you have
lived for the right idea and history
will remember you fondly